Jake is with us in Michigan to start off
this hour hey Jake how can we help you
hey Dave and Rachel thanks for taking my
call today sure what's up yeah I just
had a quick question for you
a few years ago I made some dumb butt
mistakes with credit cards and about a
year ago
this was before I found you guys and
your team I had signed up with a debt
relief company where they consolidated
all my debt and I pay them now and then
they have been settling some of the
accounts but the issue I'm having now is
my my brother introduced me to you and
your team and he's been all over me
about the getting a hold of these people
because that they're telling me that
they're going to have the debt paid off
in five years and it seems like I might
be able to do it a little bit quicker I
just don't know how to leave or how to I
guess figure out I guess I'm just afraid
to leave it in case I can't pay it off
quicker yeah well let's understand that
they're not paying the debt right now
right you know that you didn't
consolidate your debt you just quit
paying it right that's all you've done
and they're collecting a check from you
and then every so often as they pile up
some of those checks they use that money
to settle one of these debts that have
gone bad because you're in default on
all of them right you've completely
trashed your credit pretty much yeah
yeah that's what this dead so how many
different accounts and what's the total
I want to say that there was about um 12
accounts in total that I involved into
the program and the total amount of debt
was around $60,000 what is it now
well they've settled about I want to say
five of the accounts and so I'm about 45
they'd settle settled about fifteen
thousand other okay so you owe about
$45,000 on seven accounts right okay and
what's your household income my income
is about 55 a year
okay so why in the world would you take
five years to pay off $45,000 yeah you
know that's that and that's what I think
about every day yeah now since I started
listening to you I would be dead prey in
two years yeah not five or sooner
especially since you're settling there's
outstanding balances forty-five and if
you settle for less because they're in
default then that of course shortens up
the time frame so yeah I'm taking this
taking control of the situation back
whatever money you paid them in fees
you've lost but you know if you've got
any balance over there with them if
they've got any money in your quote
savings account unquote have them send
that back to you and send you to all the
detail they can on everything and cancel
the service and then you're just going
to have seven different arguments until
you get seven different debts settled
okay all right they can sue you today
right and and just because you pull it
out from under this doesn't keep doesn't
make them more likely or less likely to
sue you so then you just make a list of
the smallest one and you call them and
say you know we owe you seven thousand
dollars and we can offer you three
thousand dollars in cash that's what I
got saved up if you don't want that I'm
calling the next one on the list which
you want to do it or not and you get it
in writing
and you never give them electronic
access to your checking account and you
settle them one at a time and work your
way down through it so this is why we
call the debt settlement people and the
real debt consolidation loans debt con
solid ation loans because you're paying
people to do something the work that you
can really do
and with that consolidation it's so hard
because it feels like again back to that
math thing but it's just true it's like
okay well this makes sense if it feels
like okay it's just one big debt versus
all these other debts and again the the
psychological aspect of it people fall
into so so quickly and they get sold
this this bill of goods well it feels
easier but it's not really harder
because it's not as efficient and takes
longer right and so and it's not really
that's the consolidation it's really
debt settlement and
they do the very first thing they do is
they trash your credit by putting all
your accounts into default and they keep
the first several payments into their
pocket as their fee before you start
building up any money over there to
settle the accounts with and so you
could just you could have just stopped
paying your credit cards by yourself if
you were going to use this plan it
wouldn't been the plan I'll use but you
can do that now a real debt
consolidation loan that's where you get
a new loan and the balances are rolled
into that new loan and so now you do
have literally one loan instead of
twelve and that is that's consolidation
when you consolidate something it's a
bringing together it's not a I moved it
over there and didn't pay it and so
folks when people are saying with these
debt settlement companies you see them
on the cable TV all the time when
they're saying you know that that would
you know this is debt consolidation it's
a lie it's not that consolidation you're
not consolidating anything consolidating
the very definition of the word means to
put together and so don't do that
don't do that